there's no denying 2016 was a fantastic
year for video games but 2017 is shaping
up to be even better here's a sneak peek
at the top video games of 2017 winter
the year kicks off in epic fashion with
the January release of the hotly
anticipated Resident Evil 7 the latest
entry in the franchise which has been
the industry standard in horror for over
two decades and things don't slow down
from there
winter also finally brings gamers for
honor which has been teased for
seemingly an eternity at this point then
there's also the bizarre future dystopia
horizon zero dawn and the latest Tom
Clancy game Ghost Recon wildlands Plus
realtime strategy fans get a special
treat with the release of Halo Wars 2
while fans of the superhero fighting
game injustice finally get a sequel as
well your peer people I punch above my
weight but all of that is overshadowed
by one of the most hotly anticipated
games of the year
Mass Effect Andromeda which is set to
blow mines in March as the series leaves
Commander Shepard and the entire Milky
Way behind for a galaxy full of new
characters new aliens and new moral
conundrums sure to test the bravest of
songs heck yeah our scanners are picking
up false readings they seem to think
you're dead I'm getting that everywhere
it's a pain in the ass spring fans of
the persona series have waited nearly
nine years for the next official
installment to be released but that wait
will finally end in April when persona 5
hits consoles with a new group of
students atchoo gin high school who band
together as the Phantom thieves of
Hearts and persona isn't the only series
to get a sequel in spring our last true
promises a new round of survival horror
and
nightmare-inducing creepiness while
Tekken 7 is no doubt full of people
punching each other and shouting
catchphrases went meanwhile takes the
game within the game from The Witcher
franchise and gives it the full
spotlight in a hard stone style
collectible card game with a
single-player campaign perhaps the most
intriguing title of the spring though is
Tacoma brought to you by the same minds
who created the surprise yet gone home
Tacoma takes the game's investigative
mystery feel and moves it to the
claustrophobic interior of a derelict
Space Station where something has
definitely gone wrong players have to
try and uncover the mystery of what
happened to the crew honestly it's so
creepy already we're not sure we even
want to know summer and fall
considering the gaming industry is full
of delays and outright cancellations
it's no wonder Studios a hesitant to
give their games firm release dates too
far in advance but while we don't know
for sure when these games are going to
come out here are some of the other
titles you should be able to play
sometime in 2017 inspired by old Mickey
Mouse cartoons
cuphead has captured the imagination of
retro gamers and side scroller fans
everywhere rumor has it the designers
are putting the final touches on co-op
mode so no further delays are
anticipated besides cuphead there are a
handful of other new intellectual
properties to keep an eye on this year
scalebound is an epic third-person
action game where you get to control a
freakin dragon which is always cool
[Music]
from down
days go on features more apocalyptic
survival fare only this time in one of
our nation's national parks so that's
you know it's nice and Detroit become
human fights back against urban decline
with a futuristic neo-noir story about
androids every choice has major
ramifications for the storyline
if sequels are more your thing though
don't worry because 2017 has a metric
ton of returning franchises starting
with God of War yes
Kratos is back in the story which sees
the older and more grizzled warrior
taking on a new challenge osteoporosis
I'm fallen and I can't get up no no just
kidding
he's fighting in the Norse gods and
monsters this time there are plenty of
other fan favorite franchises making a
comeback in 2017 Shenmue 3 makes its
long-awaited return after getting crowd
funded on Kickstarter Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild takes the Nintendo
classic and adds a dash of modern
gameplay Dead Island 2 moves the zombie
survival game to Los Angeles and spoke
is's on slapstick multiplayer gameplay
quake champions is the latest
first-person shooter arena showdown
agents of mayhem is the saints row 3rd
person shooter spin-off revolving around
an anti-terrorist organization crackdown
3 features an open-world sandbox and the
ability to level civilizations with
godlike powers then there's also a
Spider Man game coming from the
developers of ratchet & clank which will
no doubt somehow tie into the release of
the summer film blockbuster spider-man
homecoming and then there's Super Mario
switch a game so secret we don't even
know the actual title yet but wait
that's not all two of the biggest
releases of the year are also seagulls
South Park the fractured but whole
builds on the surprisingly great RPG
elements of South Park the stick of
truth
2
liver and even broader and more detailed
world this time parroting the superhero
genre and the mere announcement that
there would be a Red Dead Redemption -
was enough to rocket the game to the top
of everyone's wish list for next
Christmas here's hoping Santa has a huge
sleigh because he's going to need it to
carry all these great games thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]